why didn't they stick around okay
so his argument is what they were not
really fully true believers they were in
and more for themselves okay all right
let's just say i give that argument 5 10
i don't give that argument 80
credibility by the way
let's say the other side is because
trump is just so hard to work with he
fires everybody i mean he had a show the
whole show was all about what you're
fired and he's all about himself
so if you're not with him 100 he fires
you how much credibility you give to
that say you give 20 30 credibility to
that whatever it is
fine
let's go there and let's say
this guy
is not the right guy to be a president
he can't keep people around his
retention sucks and his he's not picking
the right people so as much as you say
the fbi this you pick these guys right
so the person who picks him also gets
judged for
your ability to
not choose the right person you got to
be able to hire the right people right
okay you can't find your team if you're
drunk but let me tell you where i go
here let me tell you where i go here
if if he's that terrible of a candidate
then guess what
leave it alone
you're going to win democrats so if he
is who you say he is the way you pose
that question
then why are the democrats so afraid of
this guy that's a great so so then to me
it comes back to
if that's the can like you know how
okay so say trump would have ran against
michelle not hillary who wins
so in 2016 it's not hillary it's
michelle who wins
i think michelle huh i think michelle i
think michelle i don't know by the way
let me ask you a different question say
was obama's second term
who wins obama by a landslide state's
obama's first term who wins obama okay
saints clinton against trump who wins
clinton okay
do you do you see where i'm going with
this here's where i'm going with this
the point i'm trying to make is
the right was like hell yeah hillary is
running
hell
to the yeah hillary is running why
because because she's beatable because
she's beatable she's unlikable she's
she's the worst kid
she is
there is like there's nothing about her
that's like man i want like
you know the part about obama you're
like dude you know what republicans
showed up to the first
inauguration when he gave this speech
because it was like dude the first
african you know how many republicans
yeah they should show up but no no it's
not sure it's not sure there's no such
thing as [ __ ] i'm saying republican
voters showed up not the leaders oh god
people showed up to say dude freaking
i'm witnessing history there was
something you liked about obama nothing
likeable about hillary okay so the
republicans are like [ __ ] we have
hillary runs go run run run why aren't
democrats feeling that way if you say
he's such a bad candidate
you should kind of like it's art of war
you know sometimes you got to get out of
the way the enemy when he's falling
why don't you do that yeah right why
don't you do that if he's such a bad
candidate get out of his way you're
right
step back on insurrection it's not about
him it's the ideas that they're afraid
of well to me to me they know that it's
deeper than him i i think i think to me
here's what i think to me is
um
to me is this guy is an operator
and operators are intimidating
you know why operators are intimidating
because operators don't just say things
to sam biden will say things to get
elected every
90 of people that are running for office
they'll say whatever they can to get
elected because the history is about
what it's about who got elected right
every once in a while you find a person
that you know how they say i'm gonna
kick your ass they're actually gonna
kick your ass
okay
those types of people
are very scary so to the only thing that
he
made a point that makes you think is the
following
so
let's just say
you know how how different are trump and
desantis
if they're pushing this hard
for trump to be eliminated because they
want to indict him so he can't run what
they're really saying is we would much
rather face off the scientists than face
off trumps right who do you think the
democrats would rather face
oh i totally disagree well but that's
your emotional opinion but but
but but let me just be an opinion but
fine it's your opinion but let me say
this part to you
if you are saying he lost all these
people if you are saying
why did he fire all these people if you
are saying all these are bad judgment
isn't that a terrible candidate
yeah so why are you getting in his way
well look they're not just going to sit
back and just let trump do his thing
they're going to come after him but
trump can't do anything right now
how so
he what can he do right now he's not a
president he's a former president
and who who in the white house like
obama like you think you think you know
how obama controlled the irs obama
controlled fbi obama controls cia who
does he control nobody
who does he have control over nobody
who tell me who he has control over the
military the maga community you still
have but he still owns that but that
doesn't mean anything because policies
cannot be changed on that
all i'm saying is well he has his
tentacles on people in congress like
he's not he might not be the king
anymore i don't think so the king maker
but also what do you mean all his all
his candidates won their election i get
and meanwhile you have mike pence kind
of going against him and you know the
republican establishment there's like
these proxy wars going on i want to
there's all that internal driving on the
republican party no doubt i'm taking the
angle of
your argument your argument is he's a
terrible candidate for the right okay
i'm not i'm not saying that i'm just
saying there's a ceiling with him okay
what's the ceiling 45
so who's more intimidating to the left
trump or desantis
to the left to the left
i think desantis number one desantis
doesn't have the
the
the star quality of trump not even close
so i think we're kind of like conflating
who is it trump or desantis it's like
dude it's not even freaking close but
however in a general election yeah
desantis is way more palatable to the
general electorate than trump shouldn't
that scared the democrats
i think so yeah shouldn't they be more
about let trump run
i mean i mean they're not going to just
sit there and let trump won we already
went over the list of things that
they're trying to come at him with but
then there's a contradiction in that
argument so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]